die weltberühmte promenade samt von
nizza normalerweise wäre es hier anfang
juni schon richtig voll
jetzt wird der strand verlassen nach
drei monaten im lotter und öffnet europa
seine grenzen noch wir können endlich
wieder ans meer
die ersten privat strände haben geöffnet
die strand pfleger bereiten liegestühle
und sonnenschirme vor bevor sie wissen
dass moment noch kaum jemand kommt
wir hatten corinna ihre arbeit verändert
krone an meine arbeit verändert
auch nach der öffnung haben wir bislang
nicht viele gäste die touristen sind
einfach nicht da wir versuchen den
abstand von einem meter zwischen den
gästen zu garantieren
wir tragen masken und nach jedem
besucher desinfizieren wir die lücke die
wenigen gäste an panayides strand
genießen ihre ruhe
seit juni dürfen sich die franzosen
wieder frei im land bewegen als
präsident mag radio virus den krieg
erklärt hatte durfte sich niemand weiter
als einen kilometer von der eigenen
wohnung entfernen
so kommt das leben zurück und wir sind
glücklicher wir können wieder an den
strand gehen es ist nicht mehr so wie im
krieg
dieser sommer wird anders als alle zuvor
eine große herausforderung 40 prozent
von nitz us-wirtschaft hängen am
tourismus dass löhne crespo ist das
berühmteste hotel der stadt filmstars
und politiker buchen ihre zimmer der
direktor hat lange mit sich gerungen
aber das interview geben will
ein leeres fünf sterne hotel ist keine
gute werbung unser hotel ist zu 90
prozent abhängig von individual
urlaubern ist die aus der ganzen welt
kommen um ein paar tage an der côte
d'azur und den nutzer zu verbringen
und deshalb war die ausgangssperre für
uns natürlich eine katastrophe
die katastrophe wir mussten einiges
ändern
wir haben jetzt dampf einiger um stoffe
tapeten und teppiche zu behandeln und um
die lage der kunden besonders zur 1
wir haben sogar den posten eines hygiene
managers eingeleitet eine ganze region
wartet auf touristen
die menschen hier sind vorsichtig aber
entspannt denn in nizza hat es
vergleichsweise wenige corona fälle
gegeben auch weil die regeln der stadt
deutlich strenger waren als im rest des
landes
lange bevor die zentralregierung in
paris masken bereitstellen konnte hat
netzer bereits eine million aus china
importiert und dann die eigenen bürger
verteilt es gab eine sperrstunde nach 22
uhr und drohnen über den dächern von
nizza die alles kontrollierten heute
rühmt sich der tourismusbeauftragte für
die eigenen maßnahmen
sie waren nicht immer mit den
entscheidungen der zentralregierung in
paris einverstanden
womit wir nicht einverstanden waren war
das die regierung gesagt hat wir
brauchen keine masken zu einem zeitpunkt
als wir sie gerade so bringen und
anstatt zu sagen dass sie keine masken
haben paris lieber gesagt wir haben zwar
einige aber wir brauchen sie nicht zu
verteilen das war ein fehler
der start war nicht in der lage diese
probleme zu lösen und es waren
insbesondere städte wie nizza die es
geschafft haben die bevölkerung zu
schützen mit besonders strikten
maßnahmen im benachbarten cannes wurden
sogar ganze strände mit chlor
desinfiziert reinigungstrupps haben
bürgersteige und ampeln gesäubert in
frankreich auch das lernen wir hier
zählt manchmal einfach die geste das
signal an tue was
dass es an der croisette in diesem jahr
keine goldenen palmen gab ein schock ein
roter teppich ohne stars kann hat
versucht das beste daraus zu machen und
den filmpalast in der krise kurzerhand
für obdachlose geöffnet
auch der marsch ev will die wichtigste
anlaufstelle für den täglichen einkauf
war zu hier treffen wir die deutsche
schriftstellerin christian dreher die
seit zehn jahren in cannes lebt sie
erzählt uns wie kreativ die stadt
reagiert hat verdienst mit erzeugern ins
leben gerufen hat wirklich von der stadt
von der mary organisiert dass man gemüse
bestellen konnte und das wurde einem
dann nach hause geliefert
auf dem boden kleben immer noch die
pfeile die vorgeben in welcher richtung
in krisenzeiten eingekauft werden soll
die masken machen das probieren der
delikatessen etwas komplizierter aber
die franzosen arrangieren sich mit der
neuen normalität
die ersten beiden wochen waren eine
katastrophe
es gab hier absperrungen wir mussten
fieber messen und so weiter aber seit
einer woche geht es besser
die kunden kommen zurück wir haben immer
fisch aber keiner kauft ihn jeder hier
hat fisch auf dem verkaufstisch aber
alle essen nur noch nudeln sowie im log
daten das geht weiter immer nur nudeln
und tiefgefroren ist die verkäufer
müssen darauf vertrauen dass die
franzosen wieder zu feinschmeckern
werden auf die luxus urlaub aus russland
und den golfstaaten von denen kann sonst
so profitiert werden sie noch eine weile
verzichten müssen
also für mich für mich persönlich fand
es großartig
also für die kamera war es so glaube ich
dieses gefühl wir sind unter uns wir
sind mal wir haben die stadt mal wieder
für uns
so und das ist glaube ich auch jetzt die
dieses gefühl einerseits braucht man die
touristen hier
und eigentlich möchte man sie auch
wieder nicht so richtig gerne haben
werden als ob die kamera die nicht vom
tourismus leben sag ich mal auf unsere
reise an der côte d'azur leben wir in
frankreich das fest davon überzeugt ist
das schlimmste überstanden zu haben als
wir die grenze nach italien überqueren
erfahren wir schnell wie das corona
virus bereits bestehende probleme weiter
verschärft seit jahren schon stranden
flüchtlinge die in italien angekommen
sind in ventimiglia
jetzt wo die grenzen wieder stärker
kontrolliert werden und das auffanglager
aus hygienegründen keine neuankömmlinge
aufnimmt leben etwa 300 flüchtlinge auf
den straßen der stadt
christian papieri leitet die caritas
einrichtung in ventimiglia
er macht sich große sorgen weil viele
einwohner seit der kohlekrise selbst
keine arbeit mehr haben
es kann zu spannungen kommen weil die
aufnahmebereitschaft sehr stark an den
wohlstand gebunden sagen wir es mal so
es gibt bereits schwierigkeiten und dann
ist es einfach für manche zu sagen jetzt
kommen hier auch noch die immigranten
obwohl nicht mal die französischen
touristen zu uns kommen da ist dann die
gefahr dass manche auf falsche gedanken
kommen
[Musik]
jeden tag von 9 bis 11 bietet die
caritas bedürftigen unterstützung an
hier finden vor allem die hilfe die
seitdem lockdown auch keine gelegenheit
stopps mit finden menschen wie reza der
aus indien gekommen ist um geld für ein
besseres leben zu verdienen
warum sind sie hier ich warte darauf
dass ich duschen kann
sie brauchen eine dusche ja ich habe
mich seit einer woche nicht mehr
gewaschen
wie war das in eine wohnung was haben
sie während der krise gemacht wenn sie
draußen
ich war draußen ja ohne dach über dem
kopf
ja ohne dach ohne bett ohne alles es war
schwer ich war müde
diese ganze zeit war ich müde ich habe
20 kilo verloren in der zeit seit dem
beginn der krise ist die zahl der
bedürftigen deutlich gestiegen
hotelangestellte küchenhilfen auch viele
die schon jahrzehnte in italien leben
sind ohne jobs auf einmal auf hilfe
angewiesen als die migranten hier früher
in langen schlangen standen um essen zu
bekommen haben sich die weißen in der
nachbarschaft über diese schwarzen
beklagt dieses jahr waren die italiener
selbst an der reihe
während des lockouts sind sie gekommen
haben nach evans gutschein gepackt um
hilfe gebeten für ihre miete und all
diese sachen auch die angestellten von
dario druck warte noch immer auf
versprochene unterstützung
dario hat seit einer woche wieder
geöffnet und freut sich endlich wieder
alte bekannte zu begrüßen
ohne hilfe der regierung wird das nicht
mehr lange gehen
ein paar meiner jungs haben bis heute
noch nicht wieder angefangen zu arbeiten
sie sind zwar ein kurzarbeit haben aber
immer noch kein geld erhalten und als
arbeitgeber habe ich ihnen gegenüber
natürlich gewarnt worden
ich kann was weiß ich noch einen monat
aus halten aber wenn dann keine
finanzierung kommt habe ich keine
möglichkeit mehr weitere schulden zu
machen dann ist das mathematisch
unmöglich weiter zu
im moment kann darüber nur die hälfte
seiner wenigen tische vergeben um den
mindestabstand zwischen den gästen zu
wahren
auch er hofft auf die touristen denn wer
reist sagte uns er meist weniger
ängstlich irgendwie muss es weitergehen
doch nie neben der freude über die
öffnung spüre ich auch viel unsicherheit
auf unserer reise und die sorge dass
populisten aus der existenzangst profit
schlagen
in san remo hat das berühmte
schlagerfestival im februar noch etwas
geld in die kassen gespült doch seit der
korona krise ist von finanzieller hilfe
hier nicht viel zu spüren
die fischer am hafen schimpfen über die
regierung in rom habt ihr hilfe vom
staat bekommen von der regierung hören
wir nur worte tatsachen haben wir
bislang nicht gesehen
sie sagen viele dinge aber dann kommt
nichts und jetzt wie kann es weitergehen
langsam langsam
wir warten auf die touristen wenn die
restaurants wieder aufmachen dann kaufen
sie auch wieder fisch und dann haben wir
hoffentlich auch wieder einnahmen
italien hat seinen steuerzahlern
unterstützung versprochen
aber mit den folgen der krise sind viele
auf sich allein gestellt wie ist die
situation vielleicht fischer diko mit
krise haben wir natürlich zu spüren
bekommen denn die leute gehen nicht mehr
aus dem haus
sie kommen auch nicht mehr zu uns um
fische zu kaufen
wir müssen selber kreativ werden jetzt
machen wir lieferungen frei haus wir
bringen den fisch direkt nach hause
küstenorte wie imperia sind vom
tourismus abhängig dass er wollen sie
hier sichere strände für einen sicheren
urlaub mit masken pflicht klaren
abstands regeln dass ihr sonst zu dieser
jahreszeit mir los ist erzählt tonino
seit wochen hat er nicht einmal freunde
getroffen
das ist der erste tag an dem ich kann
deshalb muss ich mich immer noch ein
bisschen eingewöhnen
ich kenne die regeln ich glaube sie sind
richtig denn sie messen uns fieber sie
registrieren unsere namen
dann können sie nachvollziehen wer hier
an den strand kommt
für die öffentlichen badestrände hat die
stadt ein pilotprojekt gestartet mit
hilfe einer app wollen sie kontrollieren
dass die gäste ausreichend distanz
wahren können
lauda gandolfo erklärt wie sie die
strände in imperia ausgemessen haben
dass jede person zur eigenen sicherheit
vier quadratmeter und jede familie zehn
quadratmeter platz haben muss
unsere stadt stehen hier am eingang und
zählen wie viele personen reingehen und
wenn die maximale anzahl erreicht ist
schließen sie den stand ich kann also
schon von rose kontrollieren an welchen
strand ich gehe
genau das ist das bequeme daran in der
app kann jeder sehen wie viele personen
an einem strand sind deshalb ganz bequem
auswählen und entscheiden
an den strandabschnitt zu gehen oder an
einen anderen strand zu fahren an dem
vielleicht weniger los ist
mittlerweile wollen weitere städte in
ligurien die app übernehmen mit dem
beginn der sommerferien dürfte es an den
küsten italiens schon bald wieder voller
werden wächst europa wieder zusammen
wir als deutsche wurde mit offenen armen
empfangen sorgen machen manch anwohnern
die touristen aus dem eigenen land
wovor ich angst habe ist dass jetzt die
ganzen eigentümer der ferienhäuser zu
uns an die küste kommen die eigentümer
aus dem corona hot spots aus dem piemont
und vor allem aus der lombardei nur
wenige urlauber sind uns auf unsere
reise begegnet am ende treffen wir sie
doch noch deutsche touristen in italien
sie regeln gelten genauso wie in
deutschland so wie hier auch aber hier
machen er ist der große unterschied
und das ist noch sehr leer ja zum glück
hat für uns die italiener hoffen dass
das nicht lange so bleibt das gerade
nach der langen zeit der geschlossenen
grenzen die sehnsucht groß ist nach
erholung und mehr